well one step no one likely thought
about when this pandemic started uh
earlier this year people impersonating
officials denise yeah it turns out that
it's a thing specifically with some
impersonating osha enforcers madison
kimbrough joining us now from osha with
more
[Music]
yes and unfortunately this isn't
anything new in recent weeks people are
posing as
osha officials have increased
osha officers are being impersonated by
individuals from the public
northern nevada has been known for these
incidents but now southern nevada has
seen an uptick
if you are a business owner this is what
you should look out for you have to
remember that if osha initiates an
investigation at your business the very
first thing they'll do
is show you their credentials which will
consist of a state id card and a badge
the osha official will then explain the
employer's rights and then let them know
why they are in their business in the
first place
an osha inspector cannot issue a
citation on spot
due to agency protocols so if someone
comes in demanding a fine must be paid
that is a red flag as far as certain
businesses being hit
lankford says he hasn't seen a pattern
but the most recent place targeted has
raised some extra concern
we just recently got a report about
somebody representing themselves as an
osha compliance officer in a bar
on fremont street on saturday night and
that one's got our attention because
we know for a fact that the compliance
officer that
it was never there apparently this
person handed the bar manager a card
that said
they were supposed to be closed but
didn't ask for any money
a reminder that it is a gross
misdemeanor to impersonate a state
officer
in nevada
langford says that if you experience
anything like this at your business you
are urged to call them directly we have
both of those numbers
up on our website reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now